Mm.
What if a dramatic surge of climate change
melted all the earth's ice overnight?
Would you wake up to find
yourself drowning underwater?
Would most of your country be submerged?
How would you enjoy slowly
choking to death? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if all the
world's ice melted ever watched an ice
cube melt and a glass of water
that's filled to the brim.
How does it change the water level?
The truth is it doesn't.
Above or below the waterline,
a melted ice cube replaces
exactly the same volume of water.
Now let's add salt to the mix.
In the case of a one cubic inch ice cube,
the water level in the glass
will rise by 0.03 cubic inches.
That rise is displaced saltwater.
It's an increase in volume of nearly
3% fairly small amount, isn't it?
But what if you apply this to the
glaciers and floating sea ice?
5.8 million square miles of
our planet is covered with ice.
If all of it were to melt overnight,
the global sea level would
rise approximately 230 feet.
That's enough to cover
London's tower bridge.
All seven continents would
be partially underwater.
There'd be no Miami and no London.
The coast of Australia would be washed
out together with 80% of its residents,
so would Venice and the Netherlands.
Things wouldn't be that bad for Africa,
but with the extreme heat waves that
follow most of the continent would be
uninhabitable. Think floods
would wash out humanity entirely.
Well, not all of it, but whoever's left,
we'll have plenty of dangers to deal with.
All that melted ice. Nice would
release carbon dioxide into the air.
Ice needs high co two concentrations
to melt in the first place.
Given that oxygen content in the
atmosphere would remain the same,
you would slowly start to
choke from breathing the air.
You'd have very little time
to climatize to the new world.
Ocean currents would change
their direction affecting
sea life with no time to
evolve to such extreme changes.
Sea creatures and polar animals
would face massive extinction.
The ones still alive would have to leave
their homes and find a better place to
live. This would result in a
decrease of human food supply.
A change in secret. It would also
mean dramatic weather changes.
Heavy rains would hit the desert,
and areas with significant
rainfall would dry out.
This would devastate agriculture
and cause a global famine.
Wind patterns will change too with
no ice to reflect the sun's rays.
The Sun would draw more moisture from the
oceans, making more clouds in the sky.
The clouds would gather first near the
mountain areas and eventually rainfall
would flood them. Oceanic hurricanes
would occur more often causing it,
even more floods.
Even the smallest earthquake off the coast
could devastate nearby regions with a
massive tsunami.
All of this would force a global migration
that governments would not be able to
deal with. The world is,
we know it would collapse.
Luckily all the ice camp melt overnight,
but it is melting.
Even the oldest ice corn that has been
storing information about the earth's
climate for one and a half million years,
if we keep adding fuel to the
climate change fire in 5,000 years,
the earth will be ice free.
Okay.